$100,000 on eight Dior bags for her
collection.
>> I hope and I assume the best that you
are not missing your salah. Not a single
salah. I hope you guys are doing your
cuz let me tell you something by looking
at the comment section. Let me tell you
something.
Islam is raising funds to establish a
masid and community center in Norway and
they urgently need your support. This
donation will be a for you because every
person that comes a step closer to Allah
through your donation, you will in be
reaping the reward. Click the link and
donate what you can. Asalam alalaykum
brothers and sisters and dear friends,
welcome to this reaction video. This is
a video that I found actually
disturbing. I can't go to the elements
of it being halal or haram for that
matter. But there is I write is I want
to talk about in this video where this
sister I know her husband. I've kind of
known of him long time ago.
Alhamdulillah. Um briefly spoken to him.
Um you know there's nothing bad I can
say. I don't know the brother like to
say anything bad about him.
Alhamdulillah. I know he used to live in
London. he moved to the um uh Dubai. But
I found this video very disturbing in
many ways. Um and I'm going to come to
about is excessive spending um showing
off um and for example the consequences
of that evil eye, black magic, all this
kind of stuff. And I'm going to go down
and boil it down to also why are they
really doing this? My opinion, why they
really doing it? And I'm sure himself
and his wife are going to be watching
this video again with me. I urge
everybody fear Allah from stering,
backbiting, name calling, whatever. Um
this is just my take on it and not that
I'm going to be saying anything but I
just want to assess the video. Let's
react to inshallah and I've got my
calculator. I'm going to be adding up uh
the stuff that she um is saying that the
birth she's given birth to a daughter, a
baby girl and this is all the cost that
she has charged her husband to pay. Many
problems with this but let's dissect
straight into it.
>> How much did I charge my husband to give
him our second baby? First up, we have a
customized pink G Wagon as my push
present for giving him a baby girl.
>> Okay, push present. Okay, interesting.
These days is push present. Um, how many
times I said, you know, um, screamed in
pain, etc. But anyways, let's go with
it. So, 200, let's say $250,000 for that
car. Let's carry on.
>> And of course, I need a nice ride when
I'm going to be going out with her. $2
million on a new home because our family
is obviously getting bigger and we need
more space.
>> Fantastic. Let's add that. So, that's 2
million.
There we go. Fantastic. so far quarter
of um
yeah nearly two uh we're nearly on 2.5
million. Yep. Let's carry on.
>> A million dollars on renovations and
interior design to change the lighting,
flooring, and also to make a customized
pool because I'm not leaving the house
to go swimming.
>> Interesting. So, we've got nearly half
the price of the house on renovation.
So, that's £1 million. Okay, we're
already at £3 million. Let's carry on.
>> It's going to look so good. $100,000 on
eight Dior bags for her collection.
>> Okay, interesting. The baby's got a
collection of bags, eight uh so it's
$100,000
on that. And before I carry on,
inshallah, I ask Allah subhanaa tala to
protect them, protect their marriage,
protect their um uh income. I wish
nothing but the best for them. May Allah
subhanaa tala give them more. Um I just
got some for them in. So I just want to
make that clear in we should make dua
brothers and sisters. Alhamdulillah. um
there is uh nothing wrong with them earn
this income etc. It's just I have other
issues which I'm going to come to in so
may Allahh protect them from evil eyes
and protect their marriage protect their
child may Allah make their children
righteous uh um children in that for
them when they have gone which we know
is inah let's carry on
>> and $80,000 on a new Van Clee collection
for her because she's going to be taking
this down the generations and passing it
on because it's so timeless. Okay. So,
we've got £80,000.
£80,000. Great.
>> £10,000 on daily postpartum massages for
a month for me and baby girl because I
need to recover from giving birth.
>> Okay. £10,000 daily for a month. So,
let's say there's 30 days. That's
£300,000.
Fantastic.
>> And a monthly budget of $50,000 for her
wardrobe.
>> Fantastic. 50,000
monthly. I don't know how long this
wardrobe will continue for going for,
but let's say it goes for half a year
for that matter. So, that's another
300,000
if I'm not mistaken
>> to spend on designer clothing, of
course. How cute are these clothes?
Honestly, I was so obsessed. $200,000 on
this customized tennis bracelet that I
got made for her.
>> Do not forget to download the Salah Pro
app, guys. It's a free app, free ads,
free kibbleinder, salah time, salah
reminders. You can book a salah
instructor, order a guided prayer mat,
find your local salah hub, watch videos
on how to pray salah. The app is
absolutely free on Android, iOS. Till
next timealam
interesting. So, alhamdulillah, you
know, there's stuff being bought for the
baby and I don't know when the baby can
wear this stuff. I find it a little bit
bizarre. You're buying stuff. It's like
me buying saying I'm buying my son size
10 trainers. Uh,
I'm not trying to be funny.
I'm so sorry. Well, like genuinely, I'm
trying not to be funny, but it's like
you're buying these necklace and stuff
like that. I mean, it's it's like me
buying like this is a a card I'm going
to buy for my child or whatever. Like, I
don't know. I just I just find it a
little bit uh weird. But anyway, it's
£200,000 on that necklace.
>> $70,000 on purchasing gold jewelry for
her because honestly, buying gold is an
investment, so it doesn't really count
as shopping.
>> Fantastic. £70,000 as well. Perfect.
>> Last but not least, $150,000 on a
personal driver and a new car for him to
drive me around in.
>> Fantastic. £150,000
on a personal car. It all comes to
nearly 42 million.4
million pounds. Now, in order to be
spending that kind of amount, you have
to be a I would say in the in nearing to
the billionaire. Yeah. Yeah. You have to
be a multi-millionaire.
multi-millionaire.
Now, obviously, there's been some things
uh accusations again in Islamic I have
to be careful with that. Accusations
about him and his finances and etc that
he had to go to Dubai. I don't know the
ins and outs. I do not care. As far as I
know, these are all made up lies. Forget
that. We know very clearly in the Quran
Allah subhana wa tala says in verse 31,
which states, "Oh, children of Adam,
take your adornment at every masid and
eat and drink, but do not go to
extravagance. Indeed he does not like
those who who commit extravagance. In a
hadith the prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said he emphasized
moderation in all things including
eating and ablution. A hadith narrated
by Abu Omama states that the worst
Muslim are those who are extravagant in
their food, clothing and speech. So
importance very important when it comes
to um extravagance. Now I'm going to go
back to Yusfam his dream that he had and
his father told him to not even share it
with his own siblings
let alone the dummy. So I hope this
family I hope and I assume the best that
you are not missing your salah not a
single salah I hope you guys are doing
your cuz let me tell you something by
looking at the comment section let me
tell you something there are so many
people that are going to be envious
jealous hating they're going to look for
your downfall they're going to be
wishing and waiting for the story of you
guys divorced you lost everything wall
empty this is why it's so dangerous
because this is what's glamorized and
you are aiding into that problem you are
not only doing that and causing harm to
yourself because the unseen world is far
more dangerous than the seen world. So
you are not only causing danger for
yourself but the argument that I have to
ask is why are you doing and I believe
you guys are traders. You say that
you're traders. I don't know the ins and
outs etc. I'm not saying anyone's trade.
I don't know the ins and outs. To me
it's a marketing campaign. This is a
fullblown marketing campaign. I
personally do not believe that you spend
a half million pounds on the child. I
think these are things that you guys
were already going to do buying a house
whatever etc. And I don't believe you
spend those amounts. I do not believe
that. It could be that it's it's like
you was already doing it and you used it
for a marketing campaign. That's to me.
And if I'm not mistaken, I even got a
message from our dear brother's wife
pertaining to trading. I got a message
random. I didn't know what it was about.
And I think she was randomly messaging
people to do trading etc. I think I just
said walaykum salam question. I didn't
understand. So you can see clearly they
are uh and I don't know where that
message long time. I have no idea where
it is. Yes. But I got the message. Yes.
Um and I think what the wife is doing is
she's selling this plat things on how to
trade etc. So to me this is how they
make money. So I don't think they go out
their way and say I'm going to show my
kids and this no they are saying this is
how we make money and we have to show
you that because there's so many
gullible people out there and I'm not
saying their method not works. I don't
know but there I have to be on the safe
side and say there are a lot of people
out there who sell courses and become
millionaires because of selling those
courses. So they're like oh how to
become a millionaire. No they actually
become a millionaire because of selling
courses. Again I don't know the ins and
outs. I don't want to go into you know
ACU assumptions. All I'm saying is guys,
there's so many people out there who
look and this is why contentment is so
key. That's what Allah says in the
Quran. If you are grateful, Allah will
increase you. But Allah doesn't say what
he would increase you in. He can
increase you in further contentment that
you're unhappy with. But let me tell
something, brothers and sisters. Please,
please do not look at these individuals
and start comparing your husband or your
wife. Now, this is a fitna for the
woman. You my dear sister are causing a
fitna to households. You know why?
Because women like adorement. They love
everything that you have there.
Alhamdulillah may Allah increase you and
give you more. You are causing fitna.
Why? Because look as men we are visual
creatures. Yes. When a man sees a
beautiful woman his eyes he cannot help
him. This is the weakness of a man.
That's why Allah says tell the believer
man to lower his gaze. And with a woman
what is it? It is adorment of the dunya.
I want this and that etc. And that's why
so many marriages break down because of
ungrateful women for that matter. Sadly,
which is what they like the prophetam
said, I went to the hellfire and I saw
the majority of inhabitants who women.
Why? Because of the ingratitude to the
husband. The husband will do good good
good.
One bad I've never seen anything good
from you. This is aim. And what do you
do? It's like imagine this is a fa for
the woman. Imagine if I was walking
around with my bank banners on my
forehead. Most of the I'll be honest
with you. No, no one will look at me uh
because my background is not that great
at all. Yeah. But I'm saying imagine I
was worth £7.3 million. That will cause
a fitna for all the other men who are
married. Yes. Who do not have those
means and their wives happen to come and
see they're not losers. They look and
go, "Oh my gosh, she's worth 7.1." In
fact, if I was about married to him, my
life would have been a bit different.
This is what happens with men when
they're out and they see women who are
beautifying theirel excessively and
they're thinking oh my gosh you know she
has something that my wife doesn't have
it causes fitna and you are outrightly
openly doing this because you're trying
to make money whatever the matter you're
causing fitna so there's the dangers of
that will affect your house and I ask
Allah to protect you do your do not miss
your salah guys make sure you give in4.5
million pounds and again I'm not going
to come and say you could have given
that to charity of course you could have
I'm going to assume that you guys if you
give £4.5 million I certainly hope and
you guys know best yourself very well I
certainly hope you give if not maybe 20%
or whatever that amount to charity I I I
genuinely assume the best in you guys
but I'm sure you guys are very
charitable and you give more that's
another thing now in totality like you
look at the comment section wall let me
be honest with you people are hating on
you guys look let me tell you something
look I'm going to show you guys let's
read some comments this is beyond
disgusting.
So motherhood has a price tag. Now great
alhamdulillah in Islam Islam tells a man
to take care of his wife. Money can't
buy class. While children in Gaza Yemen,
Syrian, Sudan, they are starving to
death. Again, I don't deem this to be
valid. If you can have evidence that
they spend four and a half million and
don't give the people charity, this is
valid. But I don't I believe they give
maybe millions in charity. I assume the
best in them. Okay. My only question is
why did you feel the need to post this
on social media? Seriously, what was the
point of bringing all the information?
Do you see people are struggling and
you're only making their life more
miserable? And this is why it's so
important to be content. Don't look at
social media for and destroy your
marriages, especially sisters. So, this
is a very um uncalculated
um uh what's it called? Irresponsible
behavior from you, my sister. With all
you respect on it, okay? And one thing
that I would say to women who are um
trying to have a lifestyle that they
would die to, let me be honest with you,
and I'm I'm just giving this I'll be
very clear. Um a man like that who earns
that kind of income, he he most
certainly he does not have one wife.
Most certainly he does not have one
wife. Let me be honest with you guys. If
you're a multi-millionaire, you have any
Let me tell you something. The woman who
talk about oh no this. Let me tell you
something. You guys will jump and
sacrifice your left arm to be married to
a man like that. Yes. Okay, someone of
social influence let alone gets so many
women who want to marry him etc. Muslim
or you know girls who are just throwing
their self at him just for one night
stands whatever believe me sisters you
do not that's why it's so important do
not ever ask Allah subhana wa ta'ala
that I want this you do not know Allah
says you might hate something which is
good for you and you might love
something which is bad for you always be
content with Allah subhanaa tala's
decreed for you know why it's so
important because you know why cuz you
don't know you know nothing about their
marriage you don't know the ups and
downs you know nothing so instead of
making like we had the wholeat
situations found like probably have
repented you know and his wife people oh
Allah give me a wife like a husband like
if you imagine the dua got answered this
is the issue we look at a glimpse of a
video that's 30 seconds and we judge it
and say I want something like this let
me tell you something yes a man like
that most certainly he has a couple of
wives most let me tell you something
spending4 half million pounds on a baby
on this amazing baby may Allah bless and
preserve it oh my gosh let me tell you
something best believe that man has
multiple for wives best believe and it's
alhamdulillahal alhamdulillah sal so
guys I mean there might be some women
they're saying you know what if the
price is right you know we don't mind
sharing our husband you know as long as
it's the price is right you know women
are more polygimous than us you know
when it comes to the price is right with
the right man that's all I have to say
inshallah may Allah subh protect you
guys and I ask um these brother and
sister who are married please be careful
and cautious because at end day this can
come to back to bite you at the end may
Allah protect you guys this was an from
myself to you guys. Till next time.
Do not forget to download the Salah Pro
app. It's absolutely free, brother.
We're a charity. And may Allah bless and
preserve you guys.